this morning a senate committee
questions the fbi director about
domestic extremists and the assault on
the capitol
senators are expected to ask christopher
wray what he knew
about the potential for violence on
january 6th
more than 300 people have been charged
in the riot
and at least 280 arrested chris van
cleave is on capitol hill at the site of
this morning's hearing chris good
morning
good morning this is where director ray
will be facing public questions for the
first time since the january 6 attack
now this hearing follows one last week
where former capital officials testified
blaming intelligence failures for the
lack of preparedness at the capitol
senators have been clear they want to
know more about the resources dedicated
to combating domestic extremists
and white supremacists jeremy grosklose
is among those recently charged with
obstruction of justice and violent
entry of the capitol he was seen wearing
a gas mask in the building
those arrested hail from at least 42
states
a new report from the george washington
university's project on extremism
found those arrested range in age from
18 to 70.
researchers identified 33 suspects with
military backgrounds
including one current member of the
national guard and a member of the army
reserve
36 percent with military ties were also
linked to extremist groups
including proud boys oath keepers and
the three percenters now this report
calls for the federal government to
conduct a review
of its intelligence gathering as well as
look at how it distributes domestic
terror alerts with an emphasis
on improving that communication and that
is certainly something that fbi director
ray is going to be asked about today
gail all right chris thank you very much